you're probably thinking of quantum
physics and relativity and the reason
those don't mesh is that quantum physics
the the name quanta is like little
things so it's not little things like
like your phone it's little things like
you will never be able to see them
they're so small atoms electrons
um quarks subatomic particles so that's
this is the physics and when I say
physics you ask like what is physics
really it's like a beautiful language
about
um about how those things interact and
how they work and if you give them a
little flick where does it go what
happens to it and with quantum physics
the rules of clicking a little particle
and seeing where it goes are so wonky
that you will you won't know where that
particle goes it might tunnel through a
barrier it might yeah it might like like
as if this you know
the plant on your wall could just move
through the wall all of a sudden those
types of things happen on the quantum
scale so weird things happen and you
need special math to describe those
weird behaviors so that's quantum
physics and then over here is the
opposite so it's the opposite of like
something really tiny would be something
really really big something big enough
to noticeably affect this the curvature
of space and time those are things like
black holes the sun neutron stars
supernovas like the most massive things
in the universe are described by the
language of general relativity and we
still have not been able to unify those
there's some places where the languages
don't match is as if you you translate
them and the words don't mean the same
thing so but it mathematically so so
that would be like in one place you get
a zero on in these equations another
place you get an Infinity in these
equations and you're like um well which
one's right and the truth is that we
don't know in the small cases quantum
theory seems to be very right based on
all of our experiments and in the big
cases
the relativity seems to be right based
on all of our experiments and
observations and and uh we're still
looking for that math that can bridge
the gap I don't know if you experience
the same I mean this isn't scientific
but it's kind of explaining this sort of
uh curiosity is that I've explored kind
of the nature of empathy and there are
different kinds of empaths and one of
the forms of empaths they just want to
know how and why so it seems
a little colder or a little bit less
emotionally connected to start asking
questions but that's the nature of that
empathy is like I want to understand
yeah yeah absolutely so I don't me I
don't like feel someone's emotions but I
kind of am aware of how they feel and
then I want to understand why and so I
feel like you sound like the version of
me that I'm always trying to convince
people that that I'm I'm not but I
really am because they already put me in
this box they're like you're a scientist
you must like when someone's upset or
something and I'm asking questions and I
want to understand they're like oh you
like you must just think logically and
you're not there and I'm like no I
really want to know what's going on
because I want to be able to I want to
be able to like imagine okay if I went
through this like a and then B and then
I did C and then someone told me D then
I I would feel this way and I can
understand like get to the place where
they're at and it's like a a version of
of empathizing them on a deeper level
any way of finding a way to be curious
is that you can connect with other
people you
keep asking questions eventually it'll
lead you to asking questions about other
humans and what they're interested in
and what they love and I think it's just
a I don't know I don't think this is how
most people think of science but I think
of it as another incredible way to
connect with other humans but through a
slightly different lens yeah high five I
agree I really agree which is why I
would love to to do the physics of with
racing of racing because it's not it's
not something I know anything about but
but looking at it through a physics oh
my gosh oh my gosh there's a million
engineers and oh yeah yeah funnels
underneath the car that create like a
vacuum to the ground and did you ever
get in any of that like were you ever in
any of the experiments no I just would
tell them how it felt they'd been making
okay okay I'd go out and I'd be like oh
my gosh they might they might lower the
end plate skirts on the wing a quarter
an eighth of an inch on both sides and I
was like holy crap there the whole car
is so much more grip now I can you know
the front turns so much better I oh yeah
the minuscule minuscule differences with
attitude of the car and ride height of
the car I mean I had one time they
pulled like a sixteenth of an inch of
shim it's called in the front that
lowers it a sixteenth of an inch on a
stock car which is a big car and I was
like and they actually they added no no
no they added a 32nd it was either 32nd
or 16th it was so minuscule and I was
like you'd never be able to see it with
your eyes no I was like you destroyed
the car I was like it's terrible go back
like it's so crazy how
um it the littlest things make a
difference
experimenting with you as as the the
guinea pig I love that there's these
engineers and they're like well you know
obviously we have to put a driver who
knows what she's doing in the seat and
get it going and then that's the real
feedback yeah I I've I've so many times
of course thought of like dark matter
Dark Energy
I I use the parallel of uh junk DNA like
we kind of don't understand like 95 of
our DNA but we also don't understand
like 95 of the universe and I'm like
yeah exactly I'm also fascinated with
fractals like I I will talk about that
in a second but um but I think about
that a lot and I'm just I wonder of the
micro macro of of of things and if it's
just some kind of fractal Loop but what
is your understanding of dark matter or
even your opinion at this point in time
well as like a little background to
anyone who's never heard of dark matter
the way that I first learned about it is
that one thing it does is that if you
look at a Galaxy and you look at how
stars are moving around the Galaxy they
should only be able to move so fast that
the gravity inside the Galaxy can hold
them going that fast and if if something
goes faster and I get in a galaxy it'll
fly off just like imagine you're holding
somebody's hand on the playground and
you start spinning faster and faster and
then you like your sweaty hands lose
grip and you can't hold on it's the same
in a Galaxy where something going faster
and faster around the center needs a
certain amount of mass to hold on so we
look at a Galaxy and we see how much
matter is there we're like I can see a
lot of brightness so there's five
billion stars whatever
and then you calculate or you measure
how fast those stars are moving you
calculate how fast they should be moving
and you find that many of the stars in
the universe are moving way faster than
they should be based off of how much
matter is there to hold you know
basically the the hands on the
playground like
so the so so it doesn't make sense is
what you're saying when we when you look
out and you do the you do the math on
what you're seeing in the universe and
how much
um how much mass there is based on the
mass and then how fast things are moving
they shouldn't be able to stay in orbit
to that sun anymore exactly yeah exactly
right so they shouldn't be able to stay
they should be flying off into space but
they're not they're staying in orbit
so and sometimes there's like you know a
hundred times too little Mass to hold on
to these Stars so it's significant it's
not like oh we found 99.9 of the master
like where's the rest no it's like we
found
we we found one percent of the mass in
some cases like these galaxies are way
too small based off what we see and so
the theory we've come up with is that
there's extra matter there that we
cannot see and we've called it dark
matter so there's extra stuff that and
so you know these astute curious person
would be like well could it just be our
math is wrong or could it be like
something else is there that we're not
seeing like maybe dead planets that
aren't emitting a lot of light but we
have a bunch of other experiments that
show us the same exact thing we see
light curving around galaxies and it
curves too much can we see the black
holes like do we if especially if
light's bending is that a black hole and
is the black hole what creates more mass
because there's sometimes everything up
apparently yeah I mean did you see a
couple years ago the first image ever of
a black hole came out yeah that was I
mean that was very exciting for the
science Community oh it's very exciting
for the Layman too because we've never
we've never seen it I mean that's I
think like once something is visible and
you can like put an image to it to like
really wrap your imagination around it
starts to become like the questions just
start yeah exploding in your mind so so
what you're seeing there is not actually
the black hole you're seeing light
bending around it so yes around a black
hole so yeah that could be something
that's in these galaxies that is not
bright essentially right or the entire
or yeah exactly so so we it could be a
bunch of little black holes that's one
Theory
foreign
[Music]